Hey, everybody, guess what?
It's that time again.
It's time to talk about addiction.
Specifically today,
substance abuse in teens and young people.
It's a huge problem.
Of course, it's a parent's worst fear.
So how do we deal with this?
How can we identify a kid who is at risk?
And what can be done to prevent our young ones
from developing dependency issues?
Well, to answer these questions,
I did what you do when you host a podcast.
I turn to the experts,
people like today's guest, my friend, Jessica Lahey,
returning for her second appearance on the show.
Her first being episode 282,
which was almost exactly four years ago.
Jess writes about education, parenting, and child welfare
for The Atlantic, The Washington Post,
and The New York Times.
She's the author of the New York Times bestselling book
"The Gift Of Failure."
She co-hosts a popular podcast called AmWriting
alongside another podcast alum, KJ Dell'Antonia,
that was episode 396.
And hot off the press, her second book,
and the primary focus of today's conversation,
is entitled "The Addiction Inoculation:
"Raising Healthy Kids in a Culture of Dependence."
This is the Galley copy.
The final edition looks a lot nicer,
but I think you get the idea.
In any event, as a recovering alcoholic myself,
somebody who has done battle with the demons of addiction
as well as a dada for currently,
delicately parenting to teens,
this subject is of particular personal importance
and I think a useful conversation, I suspect,
will resonate with many of you as well.
So please hit that subscribe button, click like,
leave your thoughts in the comment section below.
And without further ado,
please enjoy my conversation with Jessica Lahey.
There she is!
Wow.
Yeah, it goes--
Tell me about what's going on
in the background there.
That's unbelievable.
So my dad was a designer and he had a wall like this.
He worked in a old straw hat factory that had been converted
and he had this 20-foot high wall
and it was just covered with things he'd collected
all over the world.
And I have a picture of it
'cause it was just one of my favorite things.
In fact, that's my dad right there.
Aww.
It's just one of those things that I just,
I always loved it.
And so I knew when I got this office
that this wall was gonna be for that.
Well, two observations.
First--
Yes, sir.
You definitely win the Zoom background award.
This is the coolest.
Thank you.
(laughs)
And that's important in this moment that we're in, right?
Yeah.
Curating.
I just got really bored
with all the book titles behind me.
I was like, I could just, everybody does that.
That's what I was expecting with you.
(laughs)
This has a very kind of Peter Beard feel to it.
And I love just sort of the collecting the stuff
from around the world and having that be a part of
who you are and the stuff you,
and I don't carry a lot of stuff with me.
I'm not a big sentimental person.
So the fact that these are things I still have
is kind of a big deal.
Mm-hmm, cool.
Well, so nice to see you.
Thank you for doing this.
Thank you.
I wish that we could do it--
Thank you for having me.
In person.
I know.
We did this at your dining room table.
Just two microphones and, yeah.
And some juice.
I think it's been, how many?
It's been a couple years at this point.
Five years, yeah.
I'm only now getting over my resentment
that you cheated on me with Dax.
But I'm in a good place with it.
(laughs)
Well, it was so sad is because
those were like the last things I scheduled.
Those are some of the first things that got canceled
when the pandemic hit.
Right.
My next flight was supposed to go to Los Angeles
to do Armchair Expert and hopefully see you
and do a couple of other things.
And that was one of the first things that got canceled.
Yeah, yeah, and here we are,
one year into this whole thing.
I know, I know.
But you've got this new book coming out.
I'm super excited--
Thank you.
To talk to you about it.
It's such an important subject matter and conversation
that needs to be had.
This is a book that
I feel like should've been written decades ago.
I'm so glad that you've written it.
And it's really potent and powerful
and I think it's gonna help a lot of parents.
It's funny.
Before this book even became an idea in my head,
this was stuff that I wanted to be able to talk to you about
the first time 'round.
And we talked for whatever it was, two hours and somethin',
and only scratched the surface on the substance abuse stuff.
But that second book thing is really scary.
When you have a book, especially a book that's done well,
I didn't want to just write like the obvious next thing
or like "Gift of Failure Part Two" or whatever, the sequel.
And it took a long time to figure out
what I was gonna write about.
And in the meantime, life was happening
and lifelined me up with this topic.
I love "Gift of Failure."
I will always love "Gift of Failure,"
but this is the book that I was meant to write.
This is the book that life has brought me to this place.
And all the crappy stuff
that I had to go through to get here,
this is why it's worth it.
It's interesting that you would comment
that you weren't sure what you wanted to write about next.
'Cause it's so obvious that this is the book
that you were born to write, to me.
It's funny.
My agent is so supportive.
And I would send her ideas and she'd be like,
hmm-mm, no, I love you, but no.
This isn't it.
And then I'd send her something else.
And I was sort of circling the topic.
And keep in mind, so I got sober
when I sold "Gift of Failure."
There was this big auction.
It was like 14 editors.
We had a big auction for it.
And right after that is when I got sober,
because I knew I couldn't write the book
and continue to do what I was doing with my life.
And so you're not really supposed to do much new stuff
for about a year.
And so I was dealing with "The Gift of Failure" stuff
and trying to write that book.
And then a year after "Gift of Failure" came out,
and I had about a year sober,
I went to go speak in a drug and,
an adolescent drug and alcohol rehab, rehab for adolescents.
And I went to go do like a service thing
where you go and you do the speaking thing.
And then I sort of realized at the end,
I looked around and I'm like, wait a second,
if you guys are here 24/7,
there has to be some sort of education program.
And I had just left my full-time teaching job.
So next thing I knew, I was working,
I was getting drug tested and I was working
in a drug and alcohol rehab for adolescents
as their writing teacher.
And I did that for five years.
And it was the best teaching job ever.
And I don't think I could've written this book
without having done that work too.
So it was a combination that everything had to align
in order for this book to happen.
They ultimately phased out the adolescent component
of that facility, right?
Yeah.
If you have a kid now in Vermont
and you want inpatient treatment, it doesn't exist.
Although--
Right.
I heard the best news just the other day.
Lead singer of Phish, founding member of Phish,
and I'm not a huge Phish fan even
though I live in Vermont--
Trent, Trent, Trent--
Yes, thank you.
Trent Astanasio.
How do you say his last name?
I do not know, but he's opening.
I just saw in our local paper the other day
that he's gonna open a rehab in Vermont.
Oh, wow.
He had gone to University of Vermont.
I live just south of Burlington.
And my husband is affiliated with the University of Vermont
so I could not be more excited
because my secret hope someday
is to open a recovery high school for adolescents
in the Burlington area.
So I'm thrilled.
Wow, that would be cool.
That's weirdly ironic because the whole Phish thing
is about just smoking tons of dope, right?
(laughs)
Yeah, I'm really excited to see what he does.
It just hit the news.
Just hit our local news a couple days ago.
I've been thinking a lot lately about the current state
of the greater treatment industrial complex
because I just watched this movie called "Body Brokers."
Have you seen this film yet?
No, I haven't yet.
And it deals with--
I've been underwater, yeah.
I wanna see it, though.
I mean, it's a narrative feature,
but the writer/director is a guy who was in,
in and out of, I think, a few treatment centers,
and it deals with the insurance fraud component of it
and the kind of abuses that are occurring,
which from, and this is relevant
to what we're gonna talk about,
creates confusion and trepidation
when faced with the prospect
of whether I should put my kid in a treatment center.
Is this only gonna be, and you talk about this in the book,
is this only gonna be a breeding ground
for unhealthy behavior because of the kind of community
that you're suddenly introducing your child to.
It's so hard to know what,
I mean, right now, so many people are making money
off of treating people, which is,
you have to be able to make money somehow.
And yeah, and then there are, especially with kids,
there's so many parents just desperate
for anyone to help them.
And even if you can find a quality place to send your kid,
it's just so hard to get a kid in.
It's just a really bad spot right now.
The thing for me that I think it's important to remember
is that the new book, "The Addiction Inoculation"
is just about the prevention side.
I think one of the problems
is that there are so many people in recovery
who want to help other people who need to get better
and wanna get better.
And so the draw is for people in recovery
to go become counselors themselves.
And I think that's great.
I think that's fantastic.
But just having gone through recovery
does not make me an expert in treatment.
What I am an expert in now is prevention.
And I'm not an expert in treatment.
So when it comes to that stuff,
I will defer to the experts.
I have only my own experience.
I know I have an academic understanding of treatment
and that sort of stuff, but my wheelhouse is prevention.
Right.
And the book certainly uses that as a focus,
but interlineated throughout are a couple narratives.
Most potent in my mind, we have this girl Georgia
and this boy Brian and you kind of tell their stories
throughout the book.
And what you kind of gleaned from that
is how messy and tricky and non-linear this whole thing is,
like, once the child is addicted
or the young person is addicted,
and you admit to your own kind of inadequacies
even as being a sober person
with how challenging it becomes to try to guide that person
or figure out how to get them towards the solution.
Well, and the other big picture there,
is how unclear the research is.
At least even for the things that we think we know.
I mean, the entire chapter about Brian is about peers,
kids and their peer groups.
And the research on that,
if you were to ask someone for the short answer,
is what is the research on peer cohorts?
It would say, if your kid hangs out with kids who do drugs,
they will be more likely to do drugs.
And that just sounded a little too simple for me.
Number one, I love my job, and I'm a big research dork,
and I get to read and read and read
and translate all that stuff.
I'm also married to a scientist.
I'm married to a statistician
and a physician and an ethicist.
And so anytime I say, this just doesn't sound
clear-cut to me.
Let's dig through the research
and let's find out what the good studies are,
what the bad studies are and blah, blah, blah.
So it turns out that not only,
there are so many camps in the recovery world
and in the substance abuse world
and I wanted to try to go into this free of a camp
and try to look at all the research and figure out,
if Brian's story is that he had drug issues,
then the last thing I should have done
was let my son be his friend.
But it wasn't that simple.
So what do we do with a world that isn't very simple
and very rarely cut and dry or black and white,
that kind of thing.
And also, the big story for me with this book is
my passion is to learn stuff, learn from it,
and become a better person.
And so the last thing I wanted to do is make parents feel
any kind of shame or bad or regret.
The goal with this book is to be as empowering as possible.
Yeah, you succeeded in that regard.
But yeah, it's hard.
It's so complicated and tricky.
And I'm going to resist every impulse in my body
to not make this a personal counseling session.
(laughs)
I've got two teen daughters and--
My kids' in there.
Yeah, I know, yeah.
My daughters do not wanna be part of the podcast, though,
and I respect that.
So we're not gonna do that specifically,
but there's so many kind of universalities
that we can extract from this.
But because we didn't really talk about sobriety
and addiction in our last podcast,
which was focused on "The Gift of Failure"
and just learning and, young people and learning,
why don't we begin with your story,
which is how you open the book,
'cause I think it beautifully contextualizes all of this.
Thank you.
Oh, it's funny, asking.
I did not expect this book to be a memoir, by the way.
It just became that.
So I was raised in a family with an alcoholic parent
and lots of other alcoholics and drug addicts
sort of just sprinkled throughout the family tree,
all over the place.
And I don't think there are that many people out there
that don't have at least one out there somewhere.
But I happen to have, I think, more than average.
And what's funny is I think it's taken me a really long time
to untangle all of what it meant to be raised
by someone with a substance abuse problem.
And despite the fact that I really do think
I had a fairly idyllic childhood,
I also knew that the one thing I didn't want to be
was a person who drank too much.
And so I really went all the way over
to the abstinent end of the spectrum.
I was such a dorky teenager.
I was like the designated driver.
I became a peer drug and alcohol counselor in college.
I was like the uncoolest person in college.
I talk in the book that scene about me standing there
in like beer soaked living room in a frat house
lecturing about how alcohol is broken down to,
I was horrifying.
And I also was a resident assistant,
so I was like the narc on the floor in a dorm that was very,
had a very big drug culture.
So I just didn't really drink
or do any drugs or anything like that through college.
And then I really didn't have a problem
with drugs or alcohol until I was in my 40s.
And it just snuck up on me.
And I get that my story is a little different
from a lot of people.
There wasn't that, like, I had that first drink
and I suddenly knew what was missing from my life.
For me, it was of slow build.
And I knew for a really long time
that it was building and building and going nowhere good.
My dad actually was the one who called me
out on my drinking, which was a really big deal.
And I'm so grateful to him, so grateful to him.
Well, I think it's an interesting story.
I mean, first of all, when I think of you in college
being the narc and all of that and being the goody-goody,
I have to suspect on some level that was a fear response
to your family history.
Like, I am gonna will my way into not being that person.
And alcoholism just doesn't really work that way.
And when opportunity met whatever situation you were in,
it took hold.
And because it's not a super dramatic bottom,
it's a story less told in the kind of annals of alcoholism,
but I think it's incredibly common.
Like, the extent to which you went to hide your drinking
and all of that stuff that's indelibly alcoholic
is relatable to anybody who's in recovery.
And yet the fact that when you got sober,
your concern was that your friends would be surprised
or or thinking, well, you don't really have a problem
because you were so good at masking this for so long.
Oh, it wasn't my fear.
It what happened.
I mean, I went to my first meeting
and had to sort of come out to my friends
and I had to talk them into it.
I mean, one friend, I really had to talk her into it.
And it was a weird thing.
I was so good at hiding it.
And in fact, when my husband first read
the Galley of the new book, of "The Addiction Inoculation,"
I don't let people read stuff until it's sort of done, done.
And there was so much news to him, stuff in there.
And it was hard for him to digest,
reading that first chapter.
And then I had to send it to my parents.
And that's a whole other.
So many people say, I'm just so glad you're honest.
And I'm perfectly fine being honest
and forthright and out there,
but I also don't wanna hurt the people around me
that I love.
Sure.
And those are their stories to tell.
But as you know, the more we talk about it,
I think, the easier other people find it to talk about.
Yeah, I mean, tell me about it.
When my parents read "Finding Ultra,"
that was very terrifying.
(laughs)
They had lots of opinions, I can tell you.
So I understand that.
But it takes what it takes.
And you hit your bottom and you reckoned with the demon
and you came out the other side.
So you've got like, what,
maybe eight years now at this point?
Or coming up on eight?
Almost eight years, yeah.
Yeah, good for you, that's cool.
My sobriety date is my mother's birthday.
Wow.
Because I got so hammered at her birthday party.
That was the night, yeah, I shit at the fan, yeah.
(laughs)
And then having to--
I don't remember it.
Right.
I hear it was really bad,
but I'm kinda grateful I don't remember.
I don't know.
I don't know if I'm grateful I don't remember it
or the, whatever.
I like that it was your dad, though, that kind of--
Yeah, I do too.
Knocked on the door and brought you in,
which is pretty cool.
I do too.
And then having to contend
with "The Gift of Failure" coming out
and all the hullabaloo around that in early sobriety,
I suspect, would've been relatively overwhelming.
Actually it was even worse than that.
I don't know if we had this conversation,
but the day after I hand it in
the first draft of my manuscript for "The Gift of Failure,"
I went on a, I had been training,
a friend of mine has a horse farm
and I had been training a horse with her,
and I was just out.
My husband went with me.
He never rides with me.
He doesn't really know how to ride.
We were just out on a trail thing and the horse threw me
and I fell on my head.
And I lost my memory, I lost my ability
to read and write for a while.
And then while I was still in that post-concussive syndrome
with depression and seeing, my vision problems
and reading problems, I was teaching at,
I mean, it was just horrible.
And then my editor came back to me
on the first draft of "Gift of Failure,"
did I tell you this story?
I don't think, though.
That it was quote, unquote, that,
oh, yeah, because I didn't reveal the story
'till after we talked 'cause it was so humiliating.
I never talked about it.
That the first draft of "The Gift of Failure"
was, quote, unpublishable.
And the words ghost came out, that maybe I needed a ghost,
which for me was a ghostwriter which is so humiliating
because I, at the time, was writing a column
for The New York Times,
I write for The Atlantic for years.
And so instead, I said, I tell you what,
can I have these probationary chapters?
Just let me have two chapters to,
you lay it on me, tell me how bad my book is
and what I did wrong and what I can do better.
And she did.
And those two chapters turned into the rest of the book.
So all of that, I was just newly sober,
I had a post-concussion syndrome with depression,
it was just (retches), it was horrible.
It was really, really bad.
But--
Yeah, being humble to your core.
The host of AmWriting.
I mean, I learned a lot.
The New York Times writer
being told they need a ghostwriter, wow.
But imagine if I had been drinking
when I was in that post-concussive syndrome.
There've been a few times that I've been so grateful
that I'm not drinking anymore.
That was one.
The pandemic has been the other one.
I'm just, ugh,
I can't even imagine what that would've been like
if I was still drinking.
Well, speaking of the pandemic
and kind of transitioning into young people,
what is your kind of sense or take
on how this past year has impacted young people
perhaps differently than older people?
And then how is that related to addiction
and substance abuse?
So one of the big things that the pandemic has done
for all of us, not just kids, but all of us,
is take away our sense of control.
And for kids then, as out of control as I feel as a parent,
imagine how out of control my kid feels,
can barely leave the house.
Kids have so little autonomy in their lives to begin with.
And now all of a sudden, not only
college kids are having to stay home,
kids are having to do school from home,
some kids have very, very few spaces to call their own
and have any autonomy over,
and suddenly all of that is closing in and closing in.
My kid, I have a 17-year-old and he's going,
I'm trying to imagine what it would've been like for me
at 16 and 17 to barely leave the house for,
no dating, no leaving the house.
So taking away kids' control
does a couple of different things.
Obviously, we're seeing really high levels
of depression and anxiety.
I work with a bunch of clinicians.
When the pandemic first hit,
a bunch of us sort of parenting educators and writers
got together and created this thing called
the Parenting in Place Master Class.
And we do these sessions and,
I'm doing a session actually with a mutual friend of ours,
Julie Lythcott-Haimes.
She and I have a session coming up on older kids
and getting them out of the nest and off to college.
And the parents there and the clinicians there
are talking about just incredible of depression,
lots of anxiety, tons of suicidal ideation.
I have friends there, in this group,
who are not just clinicians,
but like work in schools with kids all the time
and they're like, I don't know what to do
with all of this sadness and despair and helplessness.
And that's what taking control away does to us.
It creates this learned helplessness,
which is, there's some great research from Martin Seligman
at the University of Pennsylvania
about the fact that when exposed to long-term helplessness,
frustration, pain, our sort of default response as humans
is to go helpless and just sort of
curl up in the fetal position.
And the way we undo that, the way we interrupt that circuit
is by giving control back.
And all of these kids have not only had the normal amount
of sort of parents in their stuff all the time
suddenly just their ability to do just about anything
and have control over just about everything
has been taken away
and learned helplessness has gone through the roof.
Some people are talking about it
in terms of, like, regressing,
which isn't entirely appropriate, but close.
I mean, lots of kids are sort of reading books
they used to read when they were 12,
but haven't looked at in a long time
as a way of giving themselves comfort and stuff like that.
My kid went through a period
where he was watching movies he'd loved
as like an elementary, like the animated stuff
that he loved as an elementary kid and, yeah.
So I think that depression, that anxiety,
those feelings of hopelessness, all of those feelings are,
really put kids at risk for substance abuse, number one,
but obviously mental health issues at the same time.
And it's incredibly hard to get help right now.
It's incredibly hard to get help right now
from a mental health perspective.
Everyone's overbooked.
A kid has to do stuff by Zoom, which is not the same thing
as being in the room with a therapist.
It's hard.
It's hard for everybody.
Yeah, I mean, we're experiencing that in our house.
Anxiety, depression, the loss of agency,
the powerlessness, the frustration
that gets baked into that.
And all of those contribute to this mental soup
that primes a young person to be susceptible to substances
in a pretty profound way.
Like, we have one, here I am talking about my family,
but I have one daughter who's very extroverted--
Cloaking is much your area.
Yeah, one very extroverted child
and one very introverted child.
And noticing how they are navigating this
in very different ways has been fascinating as well.
Yeah, I have the same situation.
One is internalizing everything
and it's very difficult to have,
to get this child to communicate about it,
whereas the other one is just a hurricane.
Like, you never know what you're gonna get.
And it's changing from hour to hour.
Yeah, and actually my introvert
has actually liked a lot of the aspects of being home more
and being in his cave.
He went nocturnal for a while too, I think.
And having all of those relationships be online
and not having to go to school,
that was working really well for a while.
But even he, I think, is starting to hit a point
where he's like, okay, it's been a year now.
I'm 17.
And it really has affected kids differently.
Some kids are thriving, honestly.
I talk to parents all the time whose kids are thriving
because they've had independent projects.
So homeschool is working for them.
Hybrid is what my kids are doing and that's working well.
But in general, it's been really hard to watch kids
have to struggle through this often by themselves.
And what is your sense as an educator
in terms of how learning is happening
when now it's all digital and on Zoom?
Yeah, so the secret sauce of teaching is engagement,
relevance, connection, interpersonal connection,
connecting the material you're learning
to something you care about.
We know that learning does not happen
when there's not an emotion tied to it.
So emotion is what allows really deep learning to happen.
And when you feel disconnected,
not just from the people you're learning from,
but from, okay, well, sure,
I am understanding that this is geometry,
but how does that relate to anything beyond the classroom?
So the really best teachers not only create
an emotional connection with their students,
they help connect the material
to something the kid cares about.
They create relevance.
So they have a sense for,
oh, this kid really likes astronomy.
Let me explain to him how geometry
and astronomy work together.
And oh, this kid over here, she likes to sew.
So let me explain how seam allowances,
how we use fractions to work with seam that kind of thing.
So that relevance is important.
But then really what it comes down to with engagement
is that emotional interest attachment stimulation
for whatever it is we're teaching
or the people that are teaching it.
And when this disconnect has happened,
at the end of the first season of the pandemic,
at least the kids already knew their teachers.
They'd been in their classrooms
with their teachers that year.
Then looking at the fall, which,
and by the way, I just have to say this
for teachers out there.
Online teaching, virtual teaching, distance learning
that is a skill that you have to learn.
It's not like something that just,
classroom teaching does not just translate to online
especially because the best kinds of teaching
don't work with me as a talking head,
just sort of (blabbers), that's lecturing
and lecturing is actually a really
poor vehicle for learning.
So the teachers that were doing sort of the best work
had to try to figure out how to adapt
whether it's project-based learning or independent inquiry
or, all of that stuff is really hard to do
in this weird talking head format.
And you've probably seen all the articles.
Here's why virtual learning or here's why Zoom calls
are so emotionally exhausting for us.
Because we're looking for social cues that aren't there.
I do a lot of speaking engagements
where I'm looking at either my own face or a blank screen.
And I'm like, these jokes landing?
Right.
I don't know.
Yeah, and when everyone's just a box on a screen,
how is the teacher supposed to really get into
what's gonna motivate that child?
It just becomes infinitely more difficult.
And kids are so astute at figuring out how to do
and runs around the rules.
Like, they'll log on and check in
and then they turn the camera off,
who knows what's going on.
I mean, I've seen it all and it's not--
Well, but think about some of the kids
for whom having the camera off as a legit concern.
Like, let's say I'm a kid who,
the women in our family have to wear headscarves
in the presence of men that are not of the same family.
So that now means if I'm online in my kitchen,
because that's the only common space
we have in our apartment,
and that now means my mom has to be in her headscarf.
Or what if I'm a kid who lives in poverty?
What if I'm a kid who lives in a shelter?
I don't wanna have the camera on.
I don't want people to see what's going on in my house.
There are very real reasons why some kids
can't engage in the same way.
And PS, some teachers are still penalizing kids
for not having their cameras on or that kind of thing.
So I think teachers, all of a sudden, it's like, hold on,
I'm now a guest in your home.
It's not like you're coming to my classroom.
What new considerations do I need to consider for that?
I've never even done that before.
Right.
It's a whole new thing that,
I'm just amazed that it's gone off
as well as it has, frankly.
Well, it'll be interesting maybe a decade from now
to really do some studies on the long-term impact of this.
It's gonna take a while, yeah.
And I say the same thing for substance abuse this year, too.
I mean, we have groups doing surveys every year
of sort of like the Monitoring the Future survey.
They look at kids' attitudes around drugs and alcohol
and their habits and stuff like that.
But I really think it is gonna take a couple of years
for us to see the full impact
and get a clear picture of what's happening.
We'll be back in a sec.
But first, if you enjoy this podcast,
and I hope you're enjoying it,
then something tells me I think you'll really dig
my latest book, "Voicing Change,"
featuring excerpts from poignant essays by
and glorious photography of some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years of doing this thing,
this podcast.
It's a gorgeous artful compendium of this show
and copious wisdom shared therein
all wrapped in a hardcover coffee table form
that provides a great taste of what we do here at the RRP,
and also serves as a beautiful keepsake or gift or primer
for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website.
Signed copies are available.
And we're shipping globally
direct to any coffee table on planet earth.
So to learn more, and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc.
That's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
Well, let's pivot into the substance abuse stuff.
The reason that you, I suspect,
the reason that you introduce the book with your story
is a means of saying, like, I understand this stuff,
I have my own history and experience with this.
And myself, also having that experience,
I feel like it equips me to better understand
and manage my parenting around this in a better way
than somebody who has no experience with this,
but I've also found that it has some downsides as well.
So talk a little bit about
kind of what you bring to this conversation
as somebody with direct experience
and where that can kind of also go sideways.
I actually don't think my direct experience
is as interesting for this book as the fact that,
the reason I wrote this book is that
I am a parent of two kids who dropped out of the uterus
with an increased risk of substance abuse.
So when the experts out there in the world
say the line or write the line,
and this is something that is said often,
is substance abuse is preventable.
Well, what does that mean?
And is it different for my kids?
And well, what about my students over here,
who I'm just trying to help them stay sober?
What is it about their lives that I need to understand
so that I can be more informed
from a trauma-based teaching perspective
and from a perspective of how do I help
so that more kids don't end up in my classroom?
And then I started digging into school programs.
What are we doing and what aren't we doing
and what could we do better?
So I'm coming at this from the perspective of a parent
who just wants to do whatever I can
that's based on actual evidence,
like reliable, good evidence.
Not just like, oh, I hope.
What can I do as a parent,
especially as a parent of kids
who are more likely to have substance abuse
during their lifetime, and as a teacher,
and as a person who,
my entire adult career has been dedicated
to helping kids feel seen and heard and known
and helping them get to a place where they are healthy
and full and so realized adults.
And all of this is part of the same picture.
So the fact that I've been through recovery,
I think that adds something interesting to the story.
But my perspective is really that of an educator
and as a parent and as someone who, fortunately,
has this platform to say, okay, if we're not doing enough,
what is it that we need to be doing differently?
And to bring the journalist side of that to this is fun,
because that means that I have to go into this
as objectively as possible.
I don't care, I happened to get better in a 12-step program,
but that's not for everyone.
And how can I be as objective as possible
and come at this from, as objective a headspace as possible?
So I tell the story about who I am
mainly because I'm gonna say some hard stuff
and I need you to, you don't have to like me,
but you do have to trust me.
And I say hard stuff in "Gift of Failure" too
and so I have to walk this line of,
I'm gonna say some really hard stuff.
But I've been there and I've made those mistakes--
Right.
And here's how I learned to do better.
So I think that's why that story is there.
I got it, I got it.
So let's talk a little bit about the difference
between adult addiction and what is unique about teens
and substance abuse.
And maybe that's an opening to talk about
the developing mind and what's particular
about a young person's experiences with drugs and alcohol.
So I like to start from the place of,
look, I am not anti-drug, I'm not anti-alcohol.
We have to keep in mind, going into this,
that just because a kid has a drink of alcohol or some drugs
does not mean that they're gonna be addicted either.
Lots of people out there on the planet,
like, probably 90% of the people out there
can go use substances and have at it.
Dr. Carl Hart's new book, "Drug Use for Grown-Ups"
talks about that.
Michael Pollan has talked about it
in "How to Change Your Mind."
If you're an adult and you don't have an issue
and you're not wired the way I'm wired, then have fun.
I'm not as interested in that picture.
Here's the thing, though.
That's adults.
Kids are a very different thing.
Because adolescents, from about puberty to the early 20s,
are in this period of unmatched brain plasticity.
The only time where the brain is developing at this rate
is from birth to two.
So adolescents is so much is happening in their brains.
They're not only wiring up the frontal lobe of their brain
that hasn't been really online yet,
which is where all that executive function,
planning, schedules all that stuff happens.
Their sort of limbic system, lower brain stuff
is sort of running the show right now.
This is just starting to come online.
Myelination is happening in the brains.
Fatty sheath is going over the neurons.
Synaptogenesis, synapses are just,
billions of synapses are happening.
And there's no retakes on this, right?
So if anything goes wrong during this period,
this period of intense, of incredible plasticity,
you can't go back and fix it.
And that's why during adolescence
drugs and alcohol do some things to the brain
that just don't happen later.
Like, there are risks to certain drugs and alcohol
to everyone, but then there are greater risks
for many of them because they mess with parts of the brain
that are in the process of growing and adapting
and connecting really, really quickly.
So that's what makes it different.
And then a lot of people call substance abuse
a developmental disorder
because teenagers are also uniquely wired
to wanna go there, right?
Right.
Novelty, risk.
Adolescents have baseline lower levels of dopamine
than little kids or adults.
So when teenagers tell you they're bored,
probably really are 'cause their dopamine levels
are just baseline lower.
But, man, drugs and alcohol really can fix that.
So they're really in a place where,
and also they're becoming,
and that's scary and not liking yourself
as sort of a part of adolescence here and there
and drugs and alcohol can kinda fix that
in the short-term too.
So taking that chunk of information
and then layering that on top of a young person
and trying to assess their level of risk,
you kind of run through this gamut of factors
from genetics and epigenetics
to adverse childhood experiences,
toxic stress, academic failure,
so talk a little bit about the factors that contribute
to a young person being at risk
and how to identify when you see,
whether it's your own child or another child,
like, how you can kind of intuit
that that person might be walking a tight rope.
So in figuring out how much risk your kid has,
I beg parents to just be really
as clear-eyed as possible about this.
It's so hard to not take things personally
'cause we feel so, our kids are like some sort of statement
about our parenting.
And man, if my kid has a risk factor,
maybe I'm a bad parent.
I would beg you to not do that
simply because a kid's risk factors are information.
And information is power in this situation.
So if I know that I've set my kid up,
like, for example, we moved
right between middle school and high school,
and transitions are really risky times for kids.
And I not only moved my kid away
during this sort of high risk time anyway,
I took him away from all of his friends.
And not only that.
I took him away from his friends whose parents I trusted
and now we're gonna go to some new place
where I don't know any of his parents' friends
and I don't know the other kids.
And so I did that.
But knowing that is really important so that I can act
based on the fact that that is something that is there.
So when you look at kids,
the first place I like to start is,
so genetics is about 50 to 60% of the picture.
So from the get-go, my kids have more risk.
Here's our risk and our prevention.
It's like an old-timey scale of justice, okay?
The heavier the risk side,
the more prevention you're gonna need to outweigh it.
So genetics, my kids got that.
And on both sides of the family, by the way.
My husband has lots of substance abuse in his family too.
So we really gave it to him from both sides.
Then on top of that, then you wanna put in epigenetics,
which is just, I grew up with someone
who used drugs and alcohol,
so therefore the stress of that
can change the way my genes express themselves.
It's not actually, they're not changing the genes,
but changing the way the genes express themselves.
So epigenetic risk, that's one.
Like, the trauma or stress of somebody in your family tree
being passed down.
And having like a residual, yeah.
And you talked about adverse childhood experiences,
and that's one of them.
So adverse childhood experiences are a list,
if you Google adverse childhood experiences or ACEs
and the CDC, you can find a quiz.
You can take your own quiz
about what your average childhood experience
rating is out of 10.
In the rehab classroom, usually my students scored
seven, eight, nine.
I had one kid once who was a 10.
He had like all of 'em.
And that affects, as many of us know,
thanks to Nadine Burke Harris,
writing about this, "In the Deepest Well,"
that that affects everything.
It affects our mental health,
it affects our physical health.
Whether I have a stroke at 80 or a stroke at 60,
I mean that can change based on my childhood experiences.
And substance abuse in the house, in the home is one of 'em.
Violence, abuse, physical and sexual abuse,
divorce, and separation.
And then there's sort of a smaller list of things
that sort of some people continue,
Nadine Burke Harris talks about a bunch of them.
Adoption is one.
Just different life,
different things that can happen during childhood.
So the adverse childhood experience is a big one.
And then there are other things like academic failure,
social ostracism, aggression towards other children.
If you see a small kid
being really aggressive towards other children,
I mean there's so many reasons to intervene in that
from, like, to get that kid some help
with their anger issues
or whatever it is that they're acting out about.
But you can see how the risk factors get all tangled up.
Because a kid who is aggressive towards other kids
is probably gonna be ostracized too.
And social ostracism and academic failure
are fairly tangled up together too, right?
So the earlier we intervene and the earlier we get kids help
for whatever their thing is,
whether it's ostracism or the bullying, whatever,
the better off they're gonna be
for their lifetime risk of substance use disorder.
Right, and on the kind of childhood trauma
or adverse childhood experience tip,
that is a very subjective experiential thing, right?
Like, we tend to think of those things,
like, oh, like an acrimonious divorce
or physical or tremendous emotional abuse in the household,
but it can be triggered by something less sort of severe
like some mild bullying.
But that child's experience of that is more traumatic
than appears on the surface.
So then does it not just become an issue of communication,
like how to figure out how to crack the code
with your child so that you can open that channel
and really be able to understand what's going on
with that person.
Well, and the people who are in the addiction is a,
or substance use disorder
is what we're supposed to be saying,
that substance use disorder is related directly to trauma.
And that's Gabor Mate of the world.
And he's written so beautifully about that.
That is a legit, talk about camps and substance abuse
and substance use disorder.
So there's the trauma camp.
There's the idea that substance abuse
is a developmental disorder.
Because adolescents, kids are just uniquely wired
to want that risk and want that novelty
and also driven by the lower brain.
And people don't often become substance users/abusers
later on in life.
If it's gonna happen, it tends to happen during adolescence.
And then there's the brain science camp as well.
So speaking of the camps,
the trauma one is a very big one.
And actually the analogy that I hate but it's so apt
is that genetics is the bullet in the gun
and that trauma is the trigger.
That that bullet could sit there forever
and there could be two kids have the same trauma
and one just is better able to deal with it
and another kid just, have that trauma that happens to them
and they're off to the races and running with addiction.
So yeah.
In thinking about this whole construct
in the context of addiction
and then thinking about "The Gift of Failure,"
I mean "The Gift of Failure" was all about
like allowing kids to fail and kind of providing them
like a little bit greater agency
than the typical controlling parent.
It's about loosening the reins in some respect.
You see my problem then, don't you?
I know, so you have this inherent conflict now
because this book is all about how and when
to intervene, right?
So how do you square this idea of allowing
and then sort of being involved
and sort of letting kids fail versus,
which kind of, would be permissive
to an exploratory phase maybe with substances or maybe not.
So when is it appropriate to kind of
be in that allowing space or to shut things down?
Yeah.
Okay, so we gotta back up then,
because the research is really clear.
Well, it's not really clear.
You have to think about confounders
when you're talking about this research.
But if you look at the research,
the data show that if you are the kind of parent
that is consistently messaging total abstinence until 21,
until it is legal to drink or use pot
or whatever the thing is,
then your child is less likely
to have substance use disorder during their lifetime.
Now, as someone who always comes at statistics and data
with a question mark in my head, I say,
well, except it would be the parents
that have the total abstinence agenda
whose kids would have less access
to blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
But either way, the reason I bring that up is that it,
the parents who are like, okay, well,
I just want them to be safe.
So as long as they're doing it in the basement
and they're not driving, it's okay.
Or if I take the keys, or if they're,
as long as they're here in the home,
or I wanna give them a sip
so that they can grow up to be like those Europeans
that have the really sort of moderate,
they're not overusing their drinking and just having enough
and it's a part of the lifetime,
their life and meals and stuff like that.
The problem is, is that that sort of European romantic myth
of raising a moderate drinker is it's not true.
Not only from the standpoint of that doesn't work for kids,
a kid whose parents have a permissive attitude
around drinking and doing drugs at home
while drinking and doing drugs before 21,
those kids are more likely to have a substance use disorder
during their lifetime.
Also, hello, Europe has the highest rates
of alcoholism in the world.
They're even starting to have to deal with that.
France has gone back and changed its guidelines
around how much is healthy drinking
because they realize, yeah, yeah, yeah,
this has always been a part of our culture.
But oh my gosh, we have a problem.
I didn't realize that, wow.
Yeah, so it's really important that we not buy into that,
but I can raise moderate drinkers
by having this sort of sip of wine with dinner.
And I have to make it really clear,
talking about my own kids.
My younger kid is livid, right?
Because he's like, this is so unfair,
because my older brother, you didn't know this stuff then.
So he got to have his first taste of wine
beyond your finger when he was an infant.
Someone had sent us this grotesquely amazing
but expensive bottle of wine,
and so I put some on my finger
and put it on my infant's tongue.
I wanted his first taste of wine to be a Chateau d'Yquem.
Then--
(laughs) How dare you?
I know.
And then there was this like,
yeah, we know you're gonna drink,
but be careful kinda thing.
And now my 17-year-old is like, this sucks,
'cause you now are like total abstinence,
absolutely not, it's illegal, we don't do that before 21.
And all I can do is say, look, I'm only modeling for you
what I wanna see in you.
Like, I want you to say,
huh, I thought I had the right data,
I thought I was doing the right thing
and I realize now I'm not
and so I'm going to change what I'm doing
to do the right thing.
Sure.
Hello?
Total abstinence in my house until age 21.
And that's fine.
But do you not run the risk, hold on,
like, if you draw that hard line in the sand,
are you not risking the behavior going underground?
Like, you're gonna cut off the communication,
you're setting up the scenario
which your kid is gonna lie to you and hide stuff from you
and do what's he's gonna do or she's gonna do
and then you're not pivy to what's going on.
Except, so the other thing we know--
For people that are only listening,
you just have the biggest smile on your face.
(laughs)
No, it's just that--
Go ahead.
This is what killed me.
The writing of this book was really hard for me.
Because I do not read my children's emails,
I do not read their text.
I have never gone on the high school portal
and looked at my kids' grades.
I don't listen to their phone calls.
I trust my children.
And until I have reason not to trust my children,
I don't search their rooms, I don't read their stuff.
That's very important to me.
Because the research also is clear on this,
is that kids who are more controlled by their parents
lie to their parents more.
It's just the reality.
So if I want my kid to be the kind of kid
who can trust me and talk to me about things,
I have to respect his privacy
and I have to put forward the idea
that I trust and respect him, okay?
So there's that.
There's also real concerted efforts
to make these conversations really common
and an understanding that you don't have that one sex talk,
you don't have one drug and alcohol talk.
And my kid's in, just last semester,
he was in a biology class and the teacher asked the kids,
how often do your parents talk to you about substance abuse?
And Finn was like, oh my God,
when does my parent not talk to me about substance abuse.
So we're having a ton of conversations about it
all the time.
We're very open about those things.
And in order to get that place
where I feel like they can trust me to talk to me,
I have to be there to listen to all the other stuff
that interest them that isn't necessarily the stuff
I wanna hear.
I have to respect them
and we have to have open communication.
And I just have to hope
that the balance I'm trying to strike
between that trust and that respect,
obviously always subject to change at anytime
if I was getting scared about my kid
or there was a plain view doctrine situation
going on in my home.
But I can't force my kid to see the world
exactly the way I see it, unless I'm showing him
that I respect him to make the decisions.
And it's a really fine line I have to cross.
And as I said, it's open to change at any time
if I'm worried that my kid is having a problem,
that could turn on a dime.
Yeah, I mean, one of the things
that I'm really proud of as a parent
is that very thing of just,
I'm talking about this all the time
and I'm sharing my own experiences.
Like, my kids have heard all these stories
of things that I've done
and I've brought them to AA meetings
and they have experience with what that world is all about.
And most of my friends are sober people.
So my kids are exposed to them.
And actually my friends are able to have
really amazing conversations with my kids.
Because those conversations are devoid
of the emotional charge that it would have
if it's me talking, right?
Right.
And as a result of that,
we have amazing open channels of communication.
Like, my eldest daughter tells me all kinds of crazy stuff
and so for me then it's about, like,
I can feel my body tensing up and I wanna react
or I have this impulse to judge
or to make some definitive statement.
And it takes all that I have to just like listen and receive
and to kind of absorb that
in a loving and compassionate way.
And I found that the more I'm able to be in that space,
the better our relationship is.
And I'm taking out an insurance policy
on maintaining that open channel of communication.
But it has its challenging moments.
And I will also say that--
Of course.
It has not been an iron clad inoculation against problems.
Oh, absolutely not.
Right, absolutely not.
None of these things are.
And I think so much of,
so much of what I hear from kids,
and I get to talk to a lot of kids and it's so much fun,
and one of things I do when I'm out at a school
talking to kids is I give them all my email address,
and I say, okay, look,
I'm gonna be talking to your parents tonight.
I want you to email me with, before that,
with the things you want me to tell your parents.
And the top three things,
I mean usually I get three things
over and over and over again.
One is, I'm not my brother, I'm not my sister,
I'm not you when you were my age.
That sort of like, I don't feel seen, heard, known
for who I am.
I feel like you're raising some imaginary kid
you wish I was and not me.
So that's really stunning to me.
I also get a lot about like,
if you are going to tell me I have to do something,
then you should have to do it too.
It's usually related to having to put down the phone.
Like, if I have to put down the phone,
why doesn't my parent?
But one of the other big things they tell me is,
I want to talk to my parents.
I really, really do.
It's just that I don't wanna talk about the stuff
they wanna talk about all the time,
which is like I don't wanna constantly
be talking about school.
Can't we talk about something else?
And so I think the reason that,
one of the chapters in the book
is about getting this conversation started
and how hard that can be.
And I talked to lots of therapists
who have to try to get kids to talk about stuff
when they don't wanna talk.
And a lot of 'em, there's some cool stuff.
Like, if you're in the same room with your kid
and they don't want to say words,
tell them to text it to you across the room.
That may feel weird and horrible and fake,
but it's actually, can be a really authentic way
of communicating.
But I mean, the reason,
in the chapter that I'm talking about,
I talk about the crazy lengths I go to
to get my kids to talk to me and tell me stuff.
But a little bit of that is me showing them
that it's really, that I want it that much,
that I want, that I am so willing to meet them
on their level in a place that they wanna talk about stuff,
that I'm willing to go to these stupid lengths of making,
recreating the show "Hot Ones"--
I was just gonna bring that up.
In my dining room.
That's one of my favorite parts of the whole book,
is the "Hot Ones" dinner--
It was so much fun.
And the questions that you came up with.
So talk a little bit about that.
Yeah, so we've loved the show "Hot Ones"
since the very beginning.
Sean Evans, I think, is a talented interviewer.
Such a talented interviewer.
And his shtick.
Partially 'cause he's an incredible researcher,
but also the shtick is that you're eating a hot wing and,
10 different hot wings of,
10 XL of hotter and hotter hot wings,
and that throws you off of your game a little bit,
get your defenses down that kind of thing.
And it's fun.
You go into that thinking it's gonna be fun.
It's a little scary, but it's fun.
So my husband, I said, let's do hot ones at home over,
at our dinner table, but we've got to come up with questions
for the kids.
And they can't be stupid questions.
They can't be prying questions.
They can't be questions that will embarrass them.
What are the 10 questions we get?
Like, what do we really wanna know?
And so we wrote 10 questions for each kid,
one to go with each wing.
And then I went and got unseasoned wings and vegan wings
and bought the full range
of that season's hot sauces, I think, and did each one.
And the kids didn't know, it was a total surprise,
and they came down.
And they were all in.
It was really fun.
They sort of smiled as soon as they understood
what was happening.
And we did the whole thing.
And we were willing to be self-effacing,
like, yep, we're this dorky.
We really do want you.
And we acknowledged the fact that it was funny
and we had a great evening.
We did end up drinking ice cream, though,
because the hottest hot wing
(laughs)
required pretty much just solid vanilla ice cream.
It was just so overpoweringly hot.
Like, two million Scoville or whatever it is.
It was crazy.
The one that they make, the last dab, it was intense.
It was really crazy.
But it worked.
I'm looking at the questions that you asked.
It's like, what about you reminds you
of one or more of your parents?
Like, provocative questions that are open-ended.
And when your mouth is on fire, I would imagine that was,
that would've been pretty hilarious.
It was also fun because some, one of the questions,
like, what about you reminds you
of one or more of your grandparents too?
And it was really interesting
that the answers really surprised me.
And we had whole discussions about the answers.
Like, oh, I thought you would've said this,
or that really surprises me.
I think you're more like your grandfather
than your grandmother that kind of thing.
So it wasn't just about the questions,
but it was about the conversation that happened
around the questions too, which was fun.
What are some of the common mistakes that parents make,
like well-intentioned parents who are trying to
institute these preventative measures
around substance abuse with their kids?
I think a lot of parents have information.
For example, lots of parents know
that the first place kids often encounter opiates
are in the medicine cabinet, right,
the leftover pills in the medicine cabinet.
And I think a lot of our hopes about,
oh, but my kid wouldn't, or that kind of stuff
keeps us from putting those opiates under lock and key
or even having the conversation about opiates
in the medicine cabinet.
Well, the vast majority of parents surveyed,
in this one survey, knew that opiates often come first
from the family medicine cabinet.
Only 10% of them were talking to their own kids
about the dangers of taking opiates
out of the medicine cabinet.
So it's also just scary.
I think one of the reasons that writing a book
about substance abuse delegates you to, like,
the bottom shelf down near the floor
at the back of the bookshelf, at the back of the bookstore,
is that this is a really scary topic.
So the only way to make it a not scary topic
is by talking about it a lot.
I mean, I think we talk about it a lot in our house
mainly because I'm proud of my recovery,
I'm proud of my parent who is now in recovery,
but they also remember when it wasn't nice.
And those conversations, especially with my kids,
I have to have conversations with my kids
that are more about whether you drink
or have your first drug or whatever
but what it looks like and feels like
when it goes from use into abuse.
What does that feel like?
Like, where is that happening?
So there are some different conversations
that I think parents are really scared of.
Rightly so.
'Cause if you start with your first conversation
as about taking drugs, that's really scary.
But if you're starting really young,
with a really little kid and you're talking about
the fact that mommy's name is on that bottle of pills
on the counter because it's for mommy.
We don't take medicines
that aren't prescribed for other people.
Or talking to them about general health and stuff like that.
If we start really, really young
and that becomes a normalized part of the conversation,
it's not nearly as scary.
And I think avoiding things that are scary
is something that we're all guilty of.
I hate having the sex conversations.
I hate it.
(laughs)
I think you're really good
at it, though.
It's horrible.
I think I say this in the book, I can't remember,
but my husband, I have two boys,
my husband tends to have more of the sex conversations.
The preferred place to do it.
We used to live right near the Dartmouth Skiway,
like we could walk to it from our house,
so chairlifts are great because you're both there
but you're not looking at each other.
You're looking straight ahead.
So you don't have to look in the eye of the person,
which is why driving and chairlifts and place like that
work really well.
Chairlifts, great place for these conversations.
Yeah, well, as--
'Cause you're trapped for a given amount of time.
(laughs)
I mean, you have to be kind of like a Jedi
in order to get a glimpse into the interior life
of a teenager.
You can't will that conversation into happening, right?
You can't come at it directly.
Like, I've just learned that I have to cast my fishing rod
in so many different directions,
trying different things, coming at it sideways,
trying to figure out what my child wants to talk about.
And then it's only in the process of doing that
and the child becoming comfortable
that something will eke out
or some something that they wouldn't have said
if you ask them directly will become clear.
And then to grab onto those moments and just hold onto them
because they don't come that frequently.
And the thing from, as a teacher, I can tell you,
is it's not just about the what you say,
it's often sometimes about the when you say it.
And when I was teaching middle school
and was watching kids just sort of screw up
all around me all the time,
you don't pounce on a kid, right,
when they make a big mistake,
and he's feeling bad about it,
and talk about how to do better next time.
Sometimes you have to wait for just the right moment.
Sometimes they need to breathe for a minute.
And sometimes, especially with substance use,
you know this, that it's never ever,
it's hardly ever that first person
that comes to you and says,
I think you've got a problem going on here.
That's gonna make you think, oh my God,
I've got a problem going on here.
Sometimes it's person 100, but it's like a puzzle.
If person one through 99 doesn't say something,
then person 100 won't click.
And sometimes it'll be person 42
and sometimes it'll be person 68.
And you can't know that ahead of time.
So there's partially just a whole timing thing
that's out of your control
in terms of when your kids are receptive.
But making sure they're sleeping well
and making sure they're eating well
and making sure that your relationship is in a place
where they trust you to have these kind of conversations
that's like the big base that you start from.
Right, of course, with that, though,
one of the things that we contend with
is they don't wanna do any of the stuff that we like,
hey, you gotta get a good night's sleep.
Like, maybe--
Right.
Eat a salad instead of this.
And they wanna have their own experience.
And it doesn't matter how much we model healthy behavior,
they want to figure out who they are
through differentiation.
And on some level, you have to allow that, right?
Like, you have to allow that.
Because it's like inception,
and you talk a lot about this in both books.
Like, you have to orient the child into an experience
where the idea that you would like them to adopt become,
they have to take ownership of that on some way,
like it's their own idea.
Otherwise, it doesn't stick.
The inception lens on this discussion.
That's a place I'd never gone.
I like it, I like it.
No, I think you're completely right.
But I think also that
there's a certain amount of learning by the,
in writing, we call it planning and pantsing.
So there's planners, people who plan an entire book;
and then there's the pantsers,
who just sorta jump in and start going.
And I think a lot of us have to do a lot of pantsing,
but at the same time we're learning as we go along.
And this stuff that we're learning as we go along
sort of informs the next iteration of what we try.
And that modeling is what we're trying to do for kids too,
which is learn from the mistakes that we make
so that they don't have to make those mistakes
or so that we can do better next time.
And the thing about like the sleeping and the eating,
one of the things I talk a lot about in both books
are logical consequences,
like making sure that they do get to feel
the logical consequences of their actions.
And if your kid is not getting enough sleep,
and, by the way, kids are getting a lot more sleep
during the pandemic.
The research on that survey seemed to show
that they're getting a fair amount,
actually quite a bit more sleep.
They used to just laugh at me,
like when I would go out and speak at schools and I'd say,
here's how much sleep you're supposed to be getting,
and they're like, that's really funny.
(laughs)
But now they're actually getting more sleep.
My kid did go through a period of being nocturnal, though.
That was really interesting.
But I had to also let him suffer a little bit when that,
I couldn't rescue him,
couldn't take stuff to school for him.
I let him sleep through his alarm actually, twice,
because he just wasn't dealing with this stuff.
But here's a really interesting thing about during the,
right now anyway, is that schools are having to be
a lot more flexible.
So this is a really great time for you to give,
let your kid feel the consequences
of some of these mistakes.
Because a lot of schools are saying,
we just can't hold kids to the same
exact rigorous standards we were before this.
So there's been a lot of opportunities
to let kids take the reins a little bit more
during the pandemic, which has been good.
Yeah, because the stakes are lower.
I mean, we've been dealing with the nocturnal thing
and our MO with it is like, okay, well, how do you feel?
Are you thinking clearly, like how's your mood?
How are your anxiety levels?
Oh, that's interesting.
Maybe you might wanna rethink this.
But not saying you have to go to bed at this time or else.
And then by dent of kind of being,
having kid gloves around it, they come into their own.
They have that inception moment where they're like,
yeah, this doesn't work for me.
But that's hard as a parent.
Right, and think about what this pandemic has been like
for kids who are trying to individuate and pull away
and have more and more and more autonomy and independence
at a time when it's being taken away from them
at every turn.
It's the only act of rebellion.
I'm gonna stay up all night.
Well that or, I've been begging parents.
Man, if you make your kids clean their room
every single morning
because you have some misplaced assumption
that an organized kid becomes an organized adult
or that a messy kid can't possibly be an organized adult,
just let go, please.
Because the only place kids tend to have
any autonomy whatsoever is in their rooms.
Just let them have their rooms
the way they wanna have their rooms right now.
In fact, my kids, at a certain point,
they just needed a change so they switched rooms.
I have a picture, at one point,
we painted my son's room entirely blue,
the color of the blue on a globe, like the oceans.
And then he took an overhead projector from my classroom
and used a sharpie and made an entire world in his room.
This would be a really great chance
to let them just do whatever they want with their rooms
so that they can have some control somewhere.
Because if they can't find it,
if don't give it to them somewhere,
they're gonna take it.
And sometimes they take it by deception.
One of the things that you get good at,
if you've spent a lot of time
in the secret societies of recovery
is you become very attuned to how people behave
when they're using, like you can spot the signs
a million miles away
and you become like a palm reader
when you encounter somebody
and you can tell kind of immediately where somebody is at
and you can just kind of read signals
in a way that a normal person
who doesn't have that experience can't.
And this is something I've been talking a lot about
with my wife, who is not in recovery
and doesn't have that much experience
with people in recovery other than myself.
And I can say to her, like if we encounter something,
oh, this is what's going on with that person.
She'd be like, really?
I didn't see that.
And I bring this up because I think it's instructive
in terms of helping parents or just anybody
identify the warning signs,
whether it's a child or an adult
who might be headed in the wrong direction.
So maybe talk a little bit about some of those cues
so that we can all be kind of more on top of things
before they get too out of control.
I mean, so the cues that I tend to look for as a parent
and as a teacher is a change.
Like, if you have a kid who is baseline fairly introverted
and likes their cave time and that person is
doing all of those things now, I'm not,
I'm more worried about any kid that has any sort of change.
As a teacher, I look for a change in grades.
As as a parent, I look for a change in attitude
and you can just sort of feel that your kid is off.
And so anytime a kid changes like that,
I'm always gonna have some sort of questioning
about what's going on during adolescence.
That could be tough 'cause it's a moving target.
Kids are changing like crazy during adolescence
But change is the big thing that I worry about.
If they're sleeping more, sleeping a lot less,
if they're eating more, eating a lot less,
if they're depressed, whereas they're normally up
or if they're up when they're normally down,
that sort of changes the thing I look for the most.
But one thing I wanted to sort of mention is that
when we talk about the risk for kids
and we're talking about sort of where we're,
where we as parents are in our heads,
you said the thing about how recovery
allows you to see things more clearly,
I also wanna make it really clear
that one of the things we talk about in recovery
is that once you've had some recovery,
once you've gone to a couple of meetings,
even if you're just faking it
and still using the whole time,
knowing that information you learn there
makes it a lot less fun to use.
And so that--
To put it mildly.
(laughs)
So that information is a lot of what I'm talking about
in the book.
And there's some really cool things I found out about.
I mean, the reason the word inoculation is in the title
is because of this thing called inoculation theory
that's really, really useful and helpful for helping kids
feel like they have the emotional wherewithal
and the capability to have good refusal skills
and to refuse when someone says,
everybody does it, or it's no big deal.
And then I learned about the fact
that most kids tend to overestimate
how much other kids want to drink and use drugs.
And so if you come at them with data,
if you come at them with knowledge,
not only does it make it less fun to use
because you're, if I'm coming at you with information
about what is happening in your brain
and what this does to your brain,
and, PS, when you say you're an eighth grader
and you're saying that everyone's trying drinking
and it's no big deal,
and I happen to know that only 24% of kids try
even a sip more, a sip or more of alcohol by eighth grade,
then I can say, sweetie, it's not everyone.
Actually, it's only 24%.
So if you've got you and 10 friends,
there's really only a couple of kids that are doing that.
So that information not only is,
gives kids the why they want,
like, because I said so does not work with kids, right?
I'm sure you're familiar with that at this point.
But here's the why does work.
And it not only works because it helps kids feel empowered
and in control, it's also a big buzzkill.
Just like going to some meetings is a big buzzkill.
And it's never as fun to be high
when you actually know that it's killing cells
in your hippocampus or it's doing what the other things are
that it does.
That's why I'm a big fan of talking to kids about the why.
Yeah, the peer group thing is so huge, though.
I know tons of kids and they'll say,
if I don't go along to get along,
then I'm not gonna have any friends,
or I'm gonna be socially ostracized,
or I'll be the only one who's not doing that.
And they're just not willing
to live on the perimeter of their peer group
for the sake of sobriety when that why
doesn't really compute.
Because when you're young, you feel bulletproof anyway.
So who cares?
Yup, yeah.
And what's interesting is that overestimation
I was just talking about.
Like, if you ask a kid
how much they think their friends drink,
they'll estimate more.
What's really interesting is, from a gender perspective,
a lot of boys will up their consumption
in order to match what that perceived norm is
even though the truth is lower than the perceived norm,
whereas girls actually will tend to withdraw.
And so if all of their friends are drinking
and wanna do that sort of stuff
or they perceive that's the case, they'll pull away.
So there's very different sort of reactions.
But knowing that, I think, is so important.
Because if we're modeling for them
what good relationships look like,
if we're modeling for them, the thing I value,
in fact, I was just talking about this earlier today.
My friends and I were talking about,
a couple of years ago, we were getting together somewhere
and a friend of mine called ahead
to the place we were going to find out
if there'd be non-alcoholic options for me there.
And I said in front of my kid,
that showed me that she loved me.
And it was at a time when he was having,
in the middle of a relationship, where he was not feeling
like he was being treated very well.
And so we were able to have this conversation
about what it is we get from relationships.
That's what I love about being friends with this person.
And what is it you like being friends with that person?
'Cause you seem to not feel very good
when you come home from his house and that kind of thing.
Right, right, right.
So the problem is all of this requires us to say,
what's happening in my relationships,
what's happening with my drinking,
what's happening with my drug use,
what's happening with the way I handle when I make mistakes
that kind of stuff.
The way we model that for kids is,
they tend to watch us more than they tend to listen to us.
I know.
Annoyingly so, unfortunately.
But you do have to walk the talk in a certain regard.
You can't expect your kid to model healthy behavior
or to do what you say if you're not doing that
in your own household.
Right, and that doesn't mean
that you have to be abstinent.
Because what I'm talking about
is I have a husband who drinks like a normal person
and they see both of that from us,
but what really worries me is this culture of sort of,
especially around women and drinking,
the whole I have to have the wine at the end of the day,
this is mommy juice, here's my wine glass
with sippy cup on top.
I saw these cups at a bookstore,
not gonna name the bookstore
'cause I happen to love the bookstore,
and they say, it said on the glass
I teach, therefore I wine.
And the idea that we're messaging to kids
that we use this drug, the drugs and alcohol,
in order to not feel stuff, to unwind,
to have to deal with our stress,
that there's no other way to do that,
that's what worries me.
And that's what I try to talk a lot about with my kids.
Tina Payne Bryson, who works,
has written a bunch of books with Dan Siegel,
she's got this great saying,
"You have to name it to tame it," right?
So with kids, helping them name their emotions
and helping them name what they're feeling,
what they're going through is the first step
to helping them talk about what's bugging them
so they don't feel like they have to have a beer
to quiet that voice, so that they don't have to resort
to medicating themselves to not, you know.
The drink I missed the most, frankly,
is the one before I go to a party
so that I can feel like I'm worthy
of walking through that door,
so I don't have imposter syndrome,
so I feel like a better version of myself.
And I think helping kids be the kind of person
who doesn't have to medicate themselves
to feel like they're enough, that's my goal with teaching,
that's my goal with parenting.
Yeah.
Well, there's certainly an epidemic
of low self-esteem, right?
And that's the heavy lifting.
Like, how can you get a child
to feel comfortable in their own skin
and inhabit their truth and stand their ground
and look people in the eye and feel good about who they are.
And so many young people struggle with that tremendously,
and the level of discomfort that that produces.
It's no mistake or it's no mystery
why substance abuse seems like a good option
because it ameliorates that immediately
and it's very dependable in that regard.
It's gonna do its job every single time.
In the short term, yeah.
Yeah, in the short term.
(laughs)
In the short term.
I mean, I think that that's the thing, is it works.
And someone asked me a couple of days ago about
the whole idea of personality
and which drug you take and that sort of thing.
And I said, what's interesting to me
is for many people they'll have that lock and key moment.
For me, it was booze.
And for another people person, Nic Sheff,
in the book "High" that he and David just put out
a couple of years ago.
Nic talks about that moment with crystal meth
where he was like, yep, I liked pot,
I liked drinking out, but crystal meth was like, oh,
that was the thing for me.
Right.
And kids often talk about it as
in terms of everyone else knew how to maneuver through life
and I just, it was like everyone else had the rules but me.
I mean, these are things we hear a lot.
But for the kids, it's like drugs and alcohol gave me
the ability to be me but better.
And through everything I do with work and with my writing,
I want kids to be that better them
so that they don't have to take something
to be them but better.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, that was certainly my experience with drinking.
But I think what's kind of crucial in this,
and you do talk about this in the book as well,
is, as parents, to be honest about these things, right?
Not to just simply vilify drugs and alcohol,
say they're horrible without acknowledging the truth
of why people use them.
Like, I think the more you can kind of
be transparent about that,
like, this is how it made me feel,
or this is why people do it,
that engenders trust in the child
so that they feel like they can come to you
with some of this information.
But when you just make it very binary,
then, as you say in the book, like that shuts down,
like that erodes the trust because the child feels like
you're being disingenuous about it.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm very clear with them.
I drank to deal with my anxiety.
My husband, he smoked a lot of pot.
(laughs)
After college, when he didn't,
he couldn't get a job in the field he wanted,
he didn't know what he was gonna do.
He'd sort of half-assed it through college.
And he just was lost and scared and bored
and lived with some people who grew pot in the basement.
So at the end, he's very clear with the kids.
He's like, look, I had to go off
to graduate school after that
and I could feel that I'd messed up my memory,
that my short-term memory was nowhere where it needed to be.
And I did that to myself.
Before my brain was done growing and maturing,
I obliterated parts of my hippocampus
because I was smoking so much pot.
We have those conversations with them.
And I talk in the book actually about the opposite thing,
being really a problem too,
is one guy, who should've known better in the book,
who I don't name him actually
'cause he was embarrassed by this,
was he made it sound,
in a way he was sort of bonding with his son
and talking about the good times in college and stuff
and made it sound a little too fun.
And his son said later on when he was in his 20s,
in retrospect, I don't think you should've made it
sound like such a good time.
Yeah, that reminds me of the section in the book
where you talk about going to the,
there's the college party where the beer pong is happening.
It's like parents weekend
and the parents are trying to look cool with the kids
and participating all of this.
And that kind of like objectivity to realize
like there's something wildly dysfunctional about this,
but also completely understandable.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, it was fascinating, because the kids at this college
decided to host a dinner for their parents.
So they wanna cook for their parents,
they're excited, they're proud, they want their parent.
And the parents are about to be in a room with their kids
and their kids' friends and parents of their kids' friends.
So there's a lot of pressure to not be the total dork,
yet a lot of us are complete total dorks.
And so the kids were all like,
I know, we'll set up the ski shot.
Here in New England, what they do is they have the ski
and then they have shot glasses attached to the ski
so everyone has to drink,
like 10 people have to do a shot at the same time.
And you could see the kids
trying to convince their parents to drink.
And the parents were,
some of 'em were really uncomfortable with it
and some of them were way in.
One dad had a shirt on that said
thirsty with a question mark
and he was clearly sort of reliving his heyday.
And we all just wanted our kids to think we were cool.
And so I was seeing this weird situation
where parents were being pressured by their children
and by the perception
among their children's friends' parents
to, just have a shot, mom.
It was really fascinating to me.
But what was really fascinating,
we're just listening in on a bunch of those conversations
about sort of how parents were feeling about,
I had my younger son there, who at the time was I think 16,
and he was watching this going on.
So I was having all these feelings about
him watching his brother
and him watching his brother's friends
and it was really a bizarre situation.
Right, well, maybe that brings up
something that we could talk about
around the differences between
how this works with college-aged kids
versus elementary school, middle school, high school
because there's kind of different inoculatory protocols
for each of these various age groups.
Yeah.
So I go, in the book, I wanna make it really clear.
Both "Gift of Failure" and this book,
like broad-based research findings
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, lots of stories, lots of fun.
But there's also like here are scripts
for things you can say
and here's like this very granular level
things you can do with your kids at every age group.
And it starts with preschool
and goes all the way up into college.
And the cool thing, I think, even going up into college
is that we still, when you talk to kids,
when you do surveys with kids, college-aged kids,
about where they get their information,
they're still getting a ton of their information
from their parents, which is great, right,
which means that we still have some influence
over our kids' perceptions, and even into college.
So there are age-appropriate,
developmentally-appropriate things you can do
at every age group to talk about prevention.
But the college thing really stunned me
in terms of the amount of alcohol that's present on campus
and how it's treated, varies by state,
varies by the culture.
The college stuff was really fascinating.
And all the research on Princeton,
about the pluralistic ignorance stuff at Princeton.
They took kegs away, because I had no idea
that Princeton was one of the heaviest drinking colleges
in the country.
Right, I didn't know that,
I got drunk at Princeton--
I didn't know.
So I've experienced that culture there.
It's been a long time.
But I didn't realize that it's like other than,
what was it, like the Indianapolis 500 or--
The Indy 500.
That there's more drinking at Princeton
than anywhere else in the country.
And it's during alumni weekend in particular.
And it's sort of like a cross between
the people coming back
and wanting to relive their heyday sort of thing.
But Princeton took advantage,
some researchers took advantage of the fact
that Princeton was like, okay,
well, we'll do something about this.
We'll get rid of kegs.
We'll say kegs are not allowed on campus anymore,
which is such a token, weird thing to do.
But they took advantage of that to sort of survey
how much the kids cared
about whether or not kegs were allowed on campus,
how much they felt other people cared about it.
And the research, what they found out
was that kids were like,
well, I actually don't care one way or the other,
but I think everyone else cares a lot.
And that was the same answer they got
from just about everyone,
which is I don't really care that much one way or the other,
but I think everybody else cares a lot.
The research coming out of the college communities also
with the advent of like wellness dorms,
I mean, these are exploding all over campuses.
And Ron Lieber has this new book called
"The Price You Pay for College," which is fantastic.
He does a lot there about college amenities.
Big, big ones are wellness dorms
because they appeal to kids who may not wanna drink
and who really do wanna get studying done,
and to parents who are looking for amenities
that they would really like to pay for.
And amenities like wellness dorms, where you get rewarded,
you have to sign contracts that you won't come back drunk
and that you won't have alcohol in the dorm.
You get rewards like some places,
this one place was giving
the more points you had for wellness categories
and working out and stuff,
you could earn towards like Fitbits and things like that.
Oh, wow.
That's a cool idea.
Yeah, and a lot of colleges now have
sober dorms altogether
so that if you're a part of the recovery community,
you can have a sober dorm, which is just fantastic.
All kinds of resources.
And I think the more people say,
yes, that's something I want,
the more those things will be available
to college-aged kids.
I'm just envisioning the conversation
between the parent and the kid.
Honey, I've got a great idea.
I know.
They've got this wellness dorm.
It's the sober dorm.
I really think this is right for you.
(laughs)
Here's how you do it.
You have that have the best food.
Like, if your focus is on wellness
and you make it really clear
that that's where the freshest fruits and vegetables
are gonna be, without saying that the fruits and vegetables
aren't fresh elsewhere, you give them some perks
to wanna be a part of that.
And actually some colleges will give them privileges
that you wouldn't normally get living in other dorms.
Yeah, I could see a lot of kids like, are you crazy?
There's no way.
See, that's the thing, though,
is that that's your perception of what,
and what's fascinating is, for me,
I would've been all in on that.
And a friend of mine, two of friends' kids
chose themselves to live in wellness dorms,
just because they didn't wanna have to give up,
they didn't wanna be in a sort of situation
where there was gonna be a lot of booze around all the time.
Or they wanted it to be quiet.
And wellness dorms tend to be quieter
than dorms where there's a lot of drinking.
I spent a lot of time thinking about
what I could've learned in college
had I been sober in college.
And I have so much admiration and respect for young people
that get sober at a very young age.
And the common refrain with that person is,
like, I'm gonna miss out on all of these experiences,
and I screwed my life up so early and it's all done.
And I'm like, you gotta be kidding me.
Like, if I had been able to get sober at like 18 or 20,
like your world just opens up to you
in such a exponential fashion.
That's the cool thing about Georgia.
Yeah.
Georgia and Brian, the two people whose stories
I really focus on in the book, I mean, they did it.
They've really pulled their lives together
at a fairly young age.
And it's been amazing to watch them.
I was at a recovery meeting near you actually
and met someone who was 18.
It was the Malibu meeting near the high school
and we couldn't find it--
Sure.
'Cause we kept going up to the high school
and it's not at the high school,
but that's where the address said it was supposed to be.
And so this guy, I met this guy
who was also looking for the same meeting
and he got sober really young too.
And I kept looking at him.
I'm like, how are you doing this?
He got sober at like 17.
And he was 26 or something and still sober.
And I'm thinking, man, you know.
And he was more in touch with who he was.
He had coping skills.
I mean, he was a young adult with coping skills.
It was just so cool to see.
It was so cool to see.
Yeah, that's cool.
I know exactly the meeting that you're talking about.
(laughs)
I probably know that person.
And that's one thing--
He was visiting from out of town actually,
which was why we were both so lost.
Well, one weird thing about meetings in Malibu is that
they call it like Rehab Riviera.
There's so many sober living houses and rehabs in that area.
So that means there's a lot of young people
who are grappling with sobriety.
But it's also, it can be very sort of transitory
'cause people are kind of coming in and coming out.
This was like an old-timers.
This was at a church
and it was right down the street from the high school
and there were just a lot of old timers there.
And it wasn't a young meeting at all.
It was actually a pretty good meeting.
I was speaking up there somewhere
and found my way to that meeting.
Yeah.
In general, recovery at LA is remarkable for many reasons,
not the least of which is how many young people
are kind of in the program.
Because so many young people come to Los Angeles
to chase their dream and they get into trouble
and they, like the cops don't mess around in LA,
like people are forced to meet their maker kinda right away,
whereas if they were somewhere else,
maybe they coulda gotten away with it a little bit longer.
And so there's this incredibly dynamic, robust community
of young people who are thriving in sobriety
and I just find that so inspirational.
But I think, when I think about Georgia
and I think about Brian in your book,
what's instructive perhaps for parents
that are trying to wrap their heads around this issue
is the nonlinear nature of all of this.
Like, these people, there's this idea that,
look, you got a problem
and now I'm gonna send you to a treatment center
or you're gonna go see this person or go to this program
and all will be well.
And that works occasionally.
But for the vast majority of sober people,
there's a rubber banding effect that takes place
that could go on for years in some cases
before recovery really locks in.
And I think it's instructive,
and hopefully you can talk a little bit about this,
for parents out there to kind of understand
that if somebody's got 30 days or 90 days
or even a year to not get overly attached to that,
in the same way you talk about in "The Gift of Failure,"
like not being attached to grades,
being more attached to the process of sobriety,
and there's gonna be some backward steps most likely
before something really connects
and you create a stable foundation of sobriety.
It's funny you say that
'cause I just realized that right behind me
I don't, I have, I actually--
I see a triangle.
That's my 24-hour chip.
Oh, cool.
That's the most important one.
I don't keep my seven-year chip up.
It's in a drawer somewhere.
But the 24-hour one is the one that means the most to me.
So that's the one that's up on my wall.
And I think, especially for kids,
I don't know if you had a chance to see this,
but there was a show that was made by MTV called
"16 and in Recovery."
And it was based at the Northshore Recovery School.
There is a consortium of an association of recovery schools
in the United States.
And this is sort of, I think, what I'm supposed to do next.
I think I'm supposed to start a recovery high school.
So anyway, this was based on the Northshore Recovery High
and it really does an incredible job
of showing what kids are up against in recovery.
Because adults can say, cool, okay?
So in recovery, they say,
I'm gonna have to get new friends
and I'm gonna have to sort of change a lot of what I do.
But then you send a kid back to their family
and maybe their parents are using
and their friends are all using
and they can't pull a geographic
and they can't do any of these other things
that adults can do.
Relapse is very much a part of kids' picture.
We would see the same kids over and over again at the rehab.
And it was always such a weird thing.
Like, someone would come in, walk into the classroom
and I didn't know they were back.
And I was so happy to see them and so sad to see them
all at the same time.
Because I love them, and I wanna hug them,
but at the same time they're there
because they're using again.
And so I think what parents need to understand
is that the journey in recovery is definitely,
definitely not linear with kids.
It's not.
Wouldn't that be great if it was?
I know.
In "The Gift of Failure," I talk about the development,
let alone recovery child development's
not a nice linear slope either.
It's all over the place like the stock market.
And what you have to just hope is that you're gonna end up
up here and not lose your shirt
and that eventually all of that learning will happen
and will end up in a better place.
What are some like simple things
that you can share, like sort of parenting tips,
if they start to see their kids
sliding in the wrong direction?
So a lot of the tips that I give in the book
are before that happens.
Like, how do we not get to the place, hopefully,
where kids are sliding in the wrong direction?
But if you do notice that your kid,
or you're worried that your kid
is sliding in the wrong direction,
then you really need to come at those conversations about,
I'm concerned that something's happening with you.
There need to be a lot of those I statements.
In fact, I teach kids
that are worried that their parents are gonna be defensive
if they come to them with a question.
To say, it makes me uncomfortable when you,
when you do this, I feel this way.
When this happens, this is how it makes me feel.
Because it's a lot harder to get defensive
about how someone feels.
And so if you were to go to your kid and say,
look, sweetie, I'm scared, I'm worried.
I see you looking sad.
And I don't want you to look sad.
I want you to feel better about yourself to, you know.
Whenever we go to kids from that place of confrontation,
that's just never gonna go well,
and lecturing really doesn't go well either.
So going to them from a place of concern as a parent
is the obvious starting place for that.
And how do you--
I think--
Sorry to interject here.
Yeah, no, no, no.
But how do you do that
and avoid the pitfalls of enmeshment?
Because you don't wanna bring your emotional baggage
to your kid and like place them in a position
where they feel like they have to shoulder
your emotional trauma.
Yeah, yeah.
Honestly, I say one of the things you can do is say that.
I'm trying to untangle my fear because I see you
possibly going down the same road I went down
and that makes me scared for myself.
There is that problem that we have, or we,
number one, we tend to view their mistakes as our failures
and that being defensive about that
just doesn't make any sense either.
They're not our report card.
Like, our kids are just not a report card for our parenting.
Because, frankly, when you were in your lowest place,
if your parents were taking that part,
do they get to take, do they need to take the blame
for you as an F when you were really using it?
Now do they get an A 'cause you're successful now,
has something changed?
I don't think that we can take our kids
as any sort of an accounting of our parenting
or a report card for our parenting.
So we need to disentangle ourselves from that
for just a little bit.
And we do that in little ways.
Like, I told my son when he started looking at colleges,
that the one thing I wouldn't do
is put a sticker on the back of my car
because I didn't wanna turn his very complicated,
very personal decision about where he went to school.
I didn't wanna turn that into some bragging point
that I get when I pull into the school parking lot.
Just making sure they believe us
when we say what we care about is them
and being supportive of them.
The other thing that really works well
is to be more focused on the process than the product.
Because when we tell our kids that what we care about
is that you're learning or becoming
or advancing forward, maturing,
but then what we show them is what we care most about
is the grade or the honors or the trophy or the whatever,
then they don't believe us.
So having more of an emphasis on process over product.
And who talks about this beautifully actually
is Lisa Damour in her second book, "Under Pressure."
She talks about the fact that one of the things we can do
is help kids, number one, helps kids reframe their stress,
help them understand, like find a way
to not fall into that whole, I'm so stressed
and therefore I'm falling apart kind of trap,
but helping kids understand that that process
is the important part.
And nice thing about what Lisa talks a lot about is that
when you focus on the process and less on the product,
it helps diffuse their anxiety
and it helps diffuse their feelings of,
yeah, but I didn't get that grade,
or yeah, but I didn't get those points.
And that anxiety sort of circle, cycle can go down.
Well, the parental self-identification piece
is so important to that, and in general as well.
Because it's almost hardwired into us as parents
to be overly emotionally involved
in the successes and failures
and pains and high highs and low lows of our children
and to create distance is what's required
in order to parent effectively.
But it's so difficult to do.
Remember when I said I give kids my email
so they can email me with their things
they want their parents to know.
And I said, the number one thing is some iteration of,
I don't know who you think your parenting, but it's not me.
And so the advice I give to parents,
I think the hardest thing I have to say to parents,
is we have to love the kids we have
and not the kids we wish we had.
That has to be our starting place.
And we can't just love them based on their performance.
Because outcome love or performance-based love,
that is incredibly emotionally damaging.
And it gets them to the place with us
where they don't trust us
when we say that we love you no matter what.
Yeah, 'cause that's the thing.
We say that, but then our behavior is pretty demonstrative
in how we react to the good grade versus the bad grade.
Yeah, we put it on the refrigerator.
Right.
And we are just kinda silent when we don't talk about the,
and the way to get away from that
is by focusing more on the process and less on the product.
Oh, that's interesting
that you got an A and your friend got an F.
Well, what did your friend do that you didn't do?
What did you do that your friend didn't do?
And what are you gonna do differently next time?
I got to work on this really cool show with Amazon
called The Stinky and Dirty Show
and it's for little, little kids,
and that whole entire show is these two,
a whole bunch of different machines
trying to get a task done and screwing it up
and not beating themselves up about it
and being supportive of each other
and figuring out what to take forward with them
and what to leave behind,
and over and over and over again.
What didn't work?
What did?
What do we leave behind?
What do we take forward with us?
And we're not gonna just blame someone else
for making a mistake.
We're not gonna pretend like the mistake never happened.
We're gonna figure it out
and learn something from this iteration.
And that's that focus on the process and less on the product
is really what's gonna help us have our kid's trust
and have them know that we support them
and that we love them.
And yes, even if they screw up, we're still gonna love you.
And so if, for example, I find out that you're doing drugs,
I'm gonna be here for you,
but I'm gonna support you in getting better.
And that my love is not changed
just because you're screwing up.
And I'm not gonna take it personally
just 'cause you're screwing up.
Right, yeah, that's the trick.
Like, not taking it personally.
Like, trying to make sure that the love is unconditional
and yet the boundary is firm.
Not indulging in judgment,
which just makes everything worse.
Like, it's a sticky wicket.
It's like a--
Try writing a book about it.
Calculus equation.
Yeah, I can.
(laughs)
Try writing a book about it.
And now, if one of my kids gets addicted,
basically, I get an F, not just for my parenting
but for my work.
So stakes are lower for you.
What are your kids think about the book?
Neither one has finished the whole thing yet.
One--
Really?
Yeah, they've read bits of it.
Like I passed the bits of it past them
that I needed for them to sign off on.
Ben, my older son, has read the story about Brian,
because Brian and Ben were really close.
He was his friend, yeah.
Yep.
And Finn, I've past it by him all of the parts
that had anything to do with him.
But at some point, I guess, they're gonna read it.
I don't know.
I thought Ben had read "Gift of Failure."
He said he only read parts of it.
And that Finn still hasn't read it.
They just don't care.
I'm not very interesting.
I'm just not that interesting.
They know they're in it.
They also know that I ran anything--
We don't need to read it, we live it.
We know you.
Yeah.
And I also think that they know that they've read the parts
that are about them.
And the rest is just embarrassing mom.
We gotta wind this down in a little bit.
But I do wanna spend a minute or two
talking about marijuana specifically.
How has like the legalization of pot
like impacted how all this operates with young people?
Yeah, it's harder.
The problem is, is we have these stupid hierarchies
about drugs, like, okay, this one.
I mean, if everything, all other things being equal,
alcohol should be illegal, right?
'Cause in terms of like deaths and illness
and all that other stuff.
Horrific.
Yeah.
But pot is so easy to get now.
I mean, perhaps delivered to your door.
Both of my kids told me even before legalization
that it would've been, it's always easier
for them to get ahold of pot
than to get ahold of cigarettes.
Which was fascinating to me.
That hadn't occurred to me.
Anyway, so I live in Vermont, I talked about this,
I talk about this in the book,
that not only did I move my kid
at a really delicate time during his adolescence,
I moved him to Vermont.
The only other place where I've smelled quite this much pot
was last time I was in Portland, I think, or Seattle.
So that made things a little more complicated.
There's also the novelty issue.
I think it was really interesting to see actually
how much adult use went up.
In general, over the last decade,
drug use across the board has been, except for vaping,
has been going down among adolescents.
And we're a little worried
about sort of the downward slope
has leveled out a little bit.
I don't know that we quite know what that means yet.
And drug use is down, in all categories, in adults too,
except pot and psychedelics.
Right.
Number one, we have legalization.
Number two, we have really interesting books
by Michael Pollan and a bunch of other people talking.
And we have what looks like some really valid use
for some drugs for PTSD and end-of-life.
I think there's some really interesting research
going on there.
But across the board, I think it's been interesting
that it's actually mostly been adults
who have had a major uptick in there, in the pot use.
Well, I don't know what it's like in Vermont.
There's no billboards in Vermont, right?
But in Los Angeles--
No.
Or is that changed?
No, Vermont's not allowed to have billboards.
We have no billboards here.
Last time I took my now 17-year-old to New York,
I had to be in Studio City for something.
And he was looking around, he said,
so this is the sushi and pot part of town, huh?
Right, that's all of Los Angeles, I think.
(laughs)
That's the whole part of the town.
I mean, it's wild to drive around Los Angeles
and see dispensaries on every corner.
Some of which look like the Apple store.
Like, they have sort of created these environments
and experiences that are,
it's no longer like a flashing green light
down a dark alley.
This is like on the main promenade.
And billboards that would have you believe
that pot is just sort of an important part
of your daily wellness routine.
And CBD is in everything and all of this stuff.
And so how does that impact the psyche of a young person?
Well, the problem is also that, among adolescents,
so our own sort of, we do have receptors
for the chemicals that are in pot in our brain
because it seems like we have these endogenous chemicals
that do sort of a similar thing,
although not in the same concentrations obviously.
And most of those are right around the hippocampus,
which is where we process and store,
our memories get formed and stored there
and especially emotional memory.
And so some of the,
there's some research I'm a little skeptical of
that shows that in heavy pot users who are younger
that their hippocampi are smaller
and that could be correlation that could,
we don't know what that is.
But there is really good research
looking at sort of how the brain functions,
and because now that we have fMRIs and things like that
we can really sort of actually see
what's lighting up in the brain as it's happening.
Memory formation is just not happening in the same way
in kids who smoke pot.
And some of that appears to be permanent.
The stunting, the hippocampus appears
to possibly have long-term ramifications.
And that really scares me.
So pot, interestingly enough,
pot, like for adults, have at it, go at it.
But for kids, because in adult,
what's so interesting is after the brain is done growing,
those problems don't seem to be as much of an issue.
It's just when the brain is in this acute,
incredibly plastic place that the environment affects it
in ways that it wouldn't normally.
And so that's why this message of delay, delay, delay.
With each passing year,
our kids risk of having substance use disorder
during their lifetime goes down.
And with each passing year,
the risks that these things do to their brain goes down.
So delay, delay, delay is sort of the message
of this whole entire book.
And here's the information
about why exactly it's important to delay.
And that rubicon is sort of around like 25, right?
Like, it's not 16.
Yeah, it depends.
It is not 16, no.
Early mid to mid 20s actually.
24, 25.
But that also depends on the kid.
And you can't force that stuff.
I mean, these are things that,
myelination and synaptogenesis,
and hooking up, wiring up the frontal lobe
to the rest of the brain, that's not stuff you can rush.
And the thing that most people are worried about is
if you don't have your full,
the full ability for everything to hook up
and everything to get myelinated
and the synapses to talk to each other in the brain
during this period, you don't get to go back.
It shuts that door, closes in the early 20s,
early to mid 20s.
So the damage is done.
As the damage done and there's no going back to fix that.
And do you find that when you communicate that
to a young person that that lands,
like they're able to hear that or is that just dismissed?
Like, my experience is gonna be different or I don't care.
There's an article I wrote back when I had a column,
I had a column in The New York Times
called the Parent-Teacher Conference
and I wrote, one column was I was sitting around
at the rehab one time and we had a full group
of really honest kids, really forthright kids.
And so I asked them, what in your most open
and receptive moment might you have heard from adults
that might've made you think differently?
And I said, I don't want you to tell me
what you think I wanna hear, or whatever.
And these were kids that pretty, they trusted me.
We'd worked together for awhile.
And for all of them, it was honest information.
Give us the information we need to make a smart decision
and then trust us to make good decisions
given that we have, we're still growing
and we're not always gonna make the right decisions,
but at least have some faith that when you tell us stuff
we can process that and make some decisions for ourselves.
So no, they might not have made different decisions,
but they all said, respect me enough
to give me the information,
respect me enough to to know that given some information
I can weigh, and here's the other problem
I'm gonna mention, is that when you say,
oh my gosh, how could you have done this?
How could you not have known that if you
got in a car with a drunk driver,
they were gonna hit a tree?
And the understanding seems to be
that kids can't weigh risk correctly
or that they don't understand consequences
and that is absolutely 100% not true.
Kids really do see consequences.
The problem is, is they weigh the potential benefits
to their actions more heavily
than they weigh the possible risks.
And when you get kids in groups,
they are more likely to take risk, which explains a lot.
And sometimes it's even if they're in groups
but they're not in the same room together.
If a kid just believes other kids are watching them,
they'll take way more risks, which explains a lot
about like TikTok videos, I suppose,
and people jumping off of high things.
And that doesn't happen in adults.
If I put you in a room with some of your friends
and have you play a video game
that asks you whether or not to make these decisions
that sort of gauge your risk,
you won't take any more chances
based on the fact that your friends are there,
but kids will.
They have a different calculus.
Sure, the calibration is different
because they're gonna over-index on social approval.
Because that feels like life or death to them.
And what feels good, right, yeah.
Right, to be ostracized or to be included is survival.
And so that's gonna weigh disproportionately
into the decision to incur a risk.
And that's why the chapter is called Wired for Risk
because they are wired to, for novelty,
all the things that they're naturally supposed to be doing
as they pull away from us and become their own adults.
We want them to wanna take some positive risks.
We want them to wanna go out there and seek novelty
because that's what's gonna make them be successful adults.
But the question is, how we moderate that
and how we present, if you have a kid who really loves risk,
you better be looking for as many ways
to introduce positive risk into that kid's life as possible.
Get them to do things that, yes, are risky
but risky in a direction that isn't
like them leaping off of the garage into a swimming pool.
And how does that risk calculus,
does that differentiate based on gender?
Yeah, I haven't read a really good study on this,
and that may just be my oversight.
But all of the stuff I've read
has been equally female/male,
like all of that stuff I was just talking about with risk,
all of his research, this is Laurence Steinberg
at Temple University.
I think all of his studies are evenly female,
male/female, 50/50.
I do know that in, from an education perspective,
I've done a lot of work researching boys in education,
and I will tell you that I did,
I wrote an article for The Atlantic
on the importance of touch, of normal social touch.
And one of the things we do know
is that boys tend to get their fuller,
they get more social touch opportunities
to experience social touch at all boys schools
because the teachers,
and especially when they're taught by men,
because men understand the need
for the roughhousing sort of thing,
whereas when they're in a co-ed environment
or they're being taught by women.
The women are like, oh, don't hit each other,
don't punch each other on the shoulder that kinda thing.
But yeah, I haven't read a lot of stuff--
That's interesting.
My instinct--
But there is stuff--
My instinct says that probably boys
are wired to take more risk,
but I'm gonna have to go look it up.
And there's actually a brand new book out
that's over on my shelf over there somewhere
called "To Raise A Boy" by Emma Brown
that I am just itching to open up,
because we need some good books on boys
and that kinda stuff.
But there is lots of stuff in your book
about gender differentials
with respect to substance use and abuse, right?
Like, girls relationships with alcohol versus boys
and how that changes depending upon age, et cetera.
So there are some--
Not just attitudes either.
I mean, girls have less of a particular enzyme
that breaks alcohol down.
And so given the fact that,
we know boys' bodies have more water in them
and girls' bodies have more fat in them
and therefore a girl can have fewer drinks
and be as drunk as a boy that has, whatever.
But also, girls are just now metabolizing the alcohol
the same way the boys are.
And so girls are getting a lot more of that effect going on.
And girls tend to drink for different reasons.
Girls tend to drink to deal with their anxiety.
There are patterns that will show up.
And what I hoped to do with this book
was show you all the patterns that have been out there
and proven themselves.
So you see a pattern that you recognize in your kid,
you can say, ah, okay,
so that's a conversation I could have.
All of these bits and pieces of information
about risk factors and about how a kid might react
those are all just so you can say,
okay, I recognize that in my kid,
or I don't recognize that in my kid.
And if so, that's information for me.
And that information is power
because now I have a starting place for our conversation.
I wanna end this with just some thoughts
on the non-discriminatory nature
of substance abuse and addiction.
If anybody is under the impression
that their parenting skills
are going to completely inoculate their child from any risk,
let me disabuse you of that notion right now.
Addiction does not discriminate.
It doesn't matter your ethnicity
or your socioeconomic class.
So maybe let's end this with not a cautionary tale,
but maybe a reality check
because we are dealing with a situation
in which addiction rates in teens,
I'm sure in the pandemic, are going through the roof.
And you quote the statistic that nine out of 10 adults
with substance use disorder report
they began drinking and taking drugs before age 18.
So this is a very real situation
with incredibly profound consequences
for young people and parents,
regardless of who you think you are.
So maybe round us out with just a takeaway on that,
on that subject.
I think there's so much potential
that's just out there waiting for us to grab it.
And a big part of that is these school programs
that work really well with parents and schools,
especially when they're working together.
A lot of the really, really good
school-based substance abuse prevention programs have,
the full curriculum is not just for the school,
but for the parents as well.
And there's such an opportunity
because so few schools are using evidence-based programs
and there are a bunch out there that are really good
and have been shown to work.
If we could get those, like if I could take any,
make any one thing happen,
it would be that we get those programs into schools
so that at the very least we're starting there
where we have a huge deficit
and that parents can share in those materials
because so much of the stuff that works in schools
there are components that work at home
and we could all sort of be on the same page about this.
But I guess if I get to be queen of the world,
it's that everybody gets early intervention
for their ACEs, their trauma, their learning deficits
all of that stuff.
That's my queen of the world wish.
Yeah, and I think I would also offer to any parent
who's contending with this or has a child
who's dabbling or dealing with an issue right now,
to the extent that you can get on top of it,
it's such an unbelievable opportunity
for a young person to start grappling
with their interior life,
to confront their trauma and their anxiety
and develop like a fluency and a language
for how to deal with challenging emotions.
Like, this is something that I knew nothing about
until I was a middle-aged man.
And the idea that a teenager
could start contending with this
is such a healthy thing and such a beautiful opportunity
for how they're gonna kind of mature into the world.
There are aspects of recovery.
I look at some of the,
there's one meeting in particular that,
it's a dual speaker meeting, two speakers in one night,
and inevitably there's some like biker guy in his 60s
who gets up there and tells this story and reveals,
says things like, I just didn't have any humility
or I didn't know how to reach out and ask for help
and no one had ever told me that that was okay.
And those are the tools
that I wish we could start giving kids younger
so that we don't have to have these people
come up to a podium and say,
I just never, ever knew how to turn to someone and say,
I need help.
Imagine having to get to 60 before you realize
that you're allowed to be sad about things and cry
and ask people for help or realize even what humility is.
I think there are aspects to going through recovery
that some of the kids I've seen
who have successfully come out the other side, other side
have incredible skills.
And there's no--
And they become incredible human beings
with so much to offer.
It's no coincidence.
Well, it's no coincidence, spoiler alert,
that really good substance abuse prevention programs
are good social, emotional learning programs.
That's at the heart of them.
That's what they are.
And they give us the tools to know how to deal,
to name and tame our emotions and that kinda thing.
Right.
Well, so good to talk to you, Jessica.
I love talking to you.
I really appreciate it.
This book, as I said at the outset,
I think is going to help a lot of people.
It's a gift to the planet.
I hope so.
So I appreciate you for that and just for who you are
and the kind of vibration
and way that you carry yourself in the world.
So thank you.
Thank you.
And I hope to do this again in person
out to the distant future.
I do too.
So let's make that happen.
Last time I was there, my kid was with me
and he got to play with the dog.
It was a great day.
Oh, that's right.
I forgot about that.
I really wish--
Yeah, that's cool.
Yeah, I really wish you could've been with us again today
and I can be there.
All right, well, make it happen.
In the meantime--
All right, sounds good.
Everybody, pick up "The Addiction Inoculation."
Wherever you buy fine books, you can find Jessica.
She's easy to find on the internet.
jessicalahey.com.
And, Jess, what's your social media?
Is it JessLahey?
I'm mostly on Twitter and that's at JessLahey.
But I'm on Instagram as at teacherlahey.
Right, cool.
And you're still doing the AmWriting podcast?
Still doing the AmWriting podcast
and we're at 250 odd episodes.
And we've never missed a week and never repeated an episode.
Oh, you're such a perfectionist.
(laughs)
We've had so much fun doing it.
When we started this, we were just three writers
trying to forget how to make it work.
And now, all three of us have written best-selling books
and we've had some really cool people on.
Very cool.
It's been such a fun ride.
Awesome.
Well, best of luck with the book
and look forward to seeing you in person.
Thank you.
Peace, let's.